now it is now 6 15 here on a tuesday
morning so here's a question
are you starting 2021 with some new
year's resolutions
well you're probably not the only one
and probably one of those resolutions is
to try and get in shape alex yeah
especially after
the pandemic but with social distancing
this will look a lot different this year
if you're trying to go to a gym
bianca holmen live at the game changer
sports gym with some tips
on how to reach all of our goals hi
bianca good morning
hey good morning alex if you're like me
and you ate
very very well over the holidays
thanksgiving christmas and new year's
tamales macaroni and cheese stuffing
yeah it's all sitting right here you
probably want to get to the gym
or at least work out at home so we're
here at game changers sports gym so
i'm here joined by regal so regal tell
me i understand
hit we've heard hit workouts what is
that because we hear that all the time
uh hit is high intensity interval
training so basically what it is
is it could be any exercise that you
want it to be you do it at a
hard pace short duration with a longer
rest in between
and people need that rusty because again
we're working out with mask on so that
can make it a little bit more difficult
to kind of really get a full breath
so tell me you got the kids out here our
quarterbacks you know y'all have a boot
camp here in the morning time
what do you have them doing well i'm
going to show you a little variation of
a hit workout that we do with our kids
here on the woodways
so what i'm going to have them do
they're going to sprint for 10 seconds
and then they're going to switch and
during that time their uh
counterparts are going to have a little
bit of rest while the other teammates
are going
all right are you guys ready you guys
ready
all right here we go in three two one
let's get it
ten nine eight
seven six looking good at five
four three two one fellas
very nice go ahead and now they get a
chance to run
now they're gonna have a chance to rest
while their teammates are jumping
on here we go fellas in three
two one let's go get it so this is full
capacity that you're supposed to be
doing this yes they're gonna go for 100
effort while they're resting so uh
the intervals are spaced out times three
two
one and relax very nicely they're
running can they do this with weights
also can there be like an exercise with
weights or push-ups can they do that all
you can do high-intensity interval
training with any type of exercise that
you want you could do it with
mountain climbers jump rolls uh jumping
jacks
squats dumbbell curls whatever you
choose yeah so you can set up like a
little circuit you know get your kids
involved get out in the backyard set up
a little circus
and then go for 100 100 30 seconds about
30 seconds and then take a minute break
all right cool stuff all right thanks
regal so my pleasure
we got one more hit we're gonna come
back again we got something else to show
y'all here at game changers
sports gym so more to come more to come
hope you're taking notes because we want
to make sure that you're healthy here
in 2021 going to send it back to you
guys in the studio
all right thank you bianca